hey what's up everyone
welcome back to culture binge the
wisecrack podcast where we explore
everything going on in the cultural
zeitgeist i am michael
uh joined as always by the dr fauci of
wisecracks virus research team alec
alec how are you today um and wisecrack
researcher and overwhelming fan favorite
serbia serbia how are you today
hi hey um it feels like we haven't been
here for a while
is it true that it's only been two weeks
or is there some gap that i think it's
been three
weeks okay last week that makes me feel
less crazy
um so we're excited to be back there's
obviously a lot to talk about because
somehow the world keeps turning even
when we are not podcasting
um so to get started we're going to keep
going
with this trend um we're cutting out
chaps still because the world is a chap
unto itself so we're just going to hit
some slaps let you know things that
we've been enjoying that are making us
happy
so let's start with serbia serbia
what's something that's slapping that's
bringing joy to your life that's helping
you forget
about the giant chap that is the world
our
fans i love all the emails that we get
and there are so many wonderful
recommendations um
dude abides is always he's a big uh
friend of wisecrack and he always has
something interesting to say
during the podcast um i think a few
weeks ago
he recommended that i watch
international shows and that has
brought me so much joy ross from dc
wrote a really interesting email a
couple weeks ago
the professor who shares his experiences
at his university that's what was really
interesting so
i just it's always such a delight when i
open my
excuse me when i open my inbox and
there's
a email from a fan makes me really happy
wow wow that was really sweet i think
now
now i feel bad that mine isn't that
sweet um alec
what is yours um so i found the greatest
most wholesome
instagram ever it's an instagram page
devoted to
microscopic videos of germs and [ __ ]
uh i've got a video clip it's called jam
and germs and everyone can search it but
but joy can't put that clip
up
so
for everyone listening and not watching
what we're seeing here is a tardigrade
those are tiny little water bears
they're microscopic they can live
in the vacuum of space and all this
crazy [ __ ] uh
i find them adorable apparently burns
thinks they're disgusting
but the instagram page is full of like
all kinds of
weird [ __ ] that comes under a microscope
and sometimes it's horrifying that this
stuff is probably crawling on our skin
but i really like it there's nice little
descriptions and it was just it's just
been a wholesome part of my week
i'm really happy for you a bear why do
they do you know why they call them
bears
because it looks like a little baby bear
okay maybe i'm going to follow that so i
can get more comfortable with the fact
that i'm a living species
in an organic world that's full of all
types of weird things like that
do those i bet that thing is on your
skin right now
yeah i remember in school when they
taught us that things like lived on us
i couldn't sleep for like two nights
because i was just i kept feeling things
crawling in my skin it was it was
horrifying but
uh i'm gonna get better at that so
everyone check out
jam and germs um okay i'll be quick uh
and i i will
a second survey here a little bit i love
our fans
and recently yeah i've had some great
wisecrack fans who have who have hit me
up on
instagram in particular and and it
shared great thoughts and been funny and
nice and kind and sometimes it bullied
me
in a nice way um so i really appreciate
that and love you guys a lot
my slap is going to be the new hbo show
how to with john wilson
i don't know if anyone else has seen
this it's a new kind of like
absurd found footage docu-series type
thing executive produced by nathan
fielder of nathan for you fame where
this filmmaker
named john wilson explores new york city
with his camera
and um answers uh sort of age-old
questions like how to have a better
memory
how to put up scaffolding uh how to
start a conversation and be good at
small talk
and he starts with these very small
things and it goes
very interesting places uh for
example the most recent episode he
starts exploring the question of how do
you have a better memory
and he ends up at a conference in a
hotel in ketchum
idaho for the mandela effect society
meeting people who who believe in the
mandela effect so
i don't know check it out and i find it
kind of uh this sort of like documentary
absurdism is nice right now it's kind of
weird it was filmed in the pre-coveted
world so it's a good one so check it out
if you can
that's so interesting yeah and i think i
think you all might like it i think
i think the culture bench family in
general might like it um now we have a
lot of fun stuff to talk about today
we're going to talk about
everyone's favorite topic college exams
we're going to talk about vaccines we're
going to talk about
what it means to go home or not for the
holidays but first i just want to remind
everyone if you
like what we do here um subscribe review
give us five stars like it on whatever
podcast service you use
and maybe if you're a social media
person tell your friends that would be
cool we'd really appreciate it so do
that if you get a chance
um and then we'll do something for you
in return so let's get into it time is
of the essence
serbia you're going to start off by
telling us about the
weird new dystopian world of college
exams
yes so university students have had a
tough time of it like we all have
but their situation is a little bit more
unique so they've had to move out of
their dorms really quickly they've had
to transition to online learning
and a new thing came about which is exam
monitoring software so i first learned
of this a couple months ago from my
cousin who's in his third year
of university and he was
telling me how stressful it is to take
his
college exams so many universities
have contracted with exam proctoring
companies that have this software that
basically
um it's it's a highly intrusive so
respondus is one such company
and they track your head and eye
movements they track your mouse clicks
and if you press a keyboard button
um they record sound in your room and
they even lock down your device
so that you're unable to access the
internet or access any
any other uh information or other
browsers
other than the one designated for
your exam some software goes a step
further and they require you to do a 360
degree scan
of the room in which you're testing to
ensure that there are no study materials
or other people in the room
and understandably many students
are angry about this highly intrusive
measure to prevent cheating
and some critics point that this
software harms
low-income students who may not have
access to
a personal computer they may not have a
webcam
and students with disabilities are also
impacted because
they might have special needs that are
not accommodated by the software
um students with children or other
dependents are also
upset about this because they may need
to avert their eyes
from the computer which could trigger an
abnormality and raise a student's
suspicion level and students state that
this software discriminates against
people
of color because facial recognition
technology has trouble recognizing
people with darker skin tones
particularly women of color so there are
people
who have tried to verify their
identification
multiple times um and some software is
so strict that
if it's unable to successfully complete
a facial recognition
students will fail the exam so
i am so angry and disturbed by this
software
i can understand the need to cut down on
cheating
but i've taken i've i've
been in school i love being a student um
and
i see how lax faculty members are and
monitoring students during in-person
exams
they're on their phones they're on their
computers or reading a book
and i've seen students cheat like by
looking at their phones to keep notes on
their desks they
even ask other students for answers
and all of these actions have been
overlooked because the professors are
preoccupied
so if faculty members don't invest this
much interest in preventing cheating
during in-person exams i think it's a
bit rich for them
to suddenly be so committed to this uh
when students are doing remote learning
um
i also have strong concerns about the
data and privacy invasion
so i'm curious what you two think before
i
i share more about how i feel i mean as
as a former
uh university professor i will say
i i do have intel from some friends that
are still in the service
that they are working to subvert these
things and be on the side of their
students
and not these [ __ ] monitoring apps
and i i know i find it really upsetting
and as you were talking about that i
couldn't help but thinking like
of emails i would be writing to a
department chair saying things like fire
me if you want but i'm not gonna do this
1984 [ __ ] to my students
um i just hate it and i i hate the idea
that that in general like the the
teleology of education still comes down
to like the exam
or the paper or whatever and not a
comprehensive view of of
learning and discussion and dialogue and
becoming an engaged person
and then the other thing i was thinking
of until you said the 360 thing
is the whole time i was thinking huh if
i was doing that right now wouldn't i
just print out giant pieces of paper and
put them on the wall across from me so
my eyeline could be right there and i
could see all the answers
um but it sucks and after i want to look
up you know what
the sort of unified response by
academics has been and i would imagine
it's like
the business professors and who else i
imagine it's like
certain departments that are really into
this and i would imagine it's like the
humanities professors
that are like rubbing their crystals
together and making sure their students
don't have to do this
um but i'm mad yeah i mean i think it's
possible that it's business but when i
was in business school
i had to take exams at home and my
professors were chill about it they were
like
yeah you have 60 minutes like email me
back so
and they didn't care and nobody said
anything about cheating i mean possibly
because it's
you know it's a graduate school and
we're adults and
well yeah and sir did this come up at
all in what you were reading is this the
thing that's coming from
like the administrative level or do you
know if this is like departments
themselves making these decisions
both okay and some professors even go a
step further and they require
you to they require students to hold up
a camera
or hold up a mirror to show the front of
the
to show the screen to ensure that nobody
has like post-it notes or other
um like little like notes and like
things that they can cheat with
it's ridiculous we just can't i just i'm
so upset alec you should talk cause i'm
just gonna rant
yeah uh i do wonder
i wonder about what is the value of
exams to begin with and i know uh
i don't know i don't have a lot of the
details at hand but i know there's a big
fiasco with the bar exam
and like they're doing it online it was
a big [ __ ] show in the end
uh there was like lots of problems with
people not being able to leave their
computer or get on and so
just the idea for example the bar exam
being this you need to sit in this room
for hours and hours and hours
uh and do this thing to become a lawyer
is that even connected to like is it
that useful for actually training
lawyers and i think
in general we can ask that question
about test uh in that
you know i'm not saying tests are
worthless or anything like that i think
for some people
it's a good motivation to sort of learn
the material but
what is it like i know michelle foucault
the french philosopher created this like
rogue school in france with his
philosopher friends and they lost their
accreditation because they refused to
give tester grades
uh i went to school that was very much
like anti
we we got grades but basically you got
an a as long as you showed up
um and i i was always the person
that like i was a good test taker so
people would often
cheat off of me uh and the people who
cheated off me are doing great one's an
engineer
she makes probably way [ __ ] more
money than i do i think she's very good
at her job but she cheated on me all the
time in high school physics and she's
doing great
i have another friend who i think works
at the department of health who is
constantly cheating on me in economics
class
i think you know that's one part of it
the other part is
i think especially for non-college
students in
in high school middle or you know all
the sort of pre-college
uh basically all your rights are
stripped as a child because there's this
concept called in local apprentice which
is like
you don't have the same sort of rights
you do in the world out of school
because the school takes the
the role of your parents and they can
basically strip you all these civil
liberties and all this [ __ ]
it's something that always sort of
bothered me um but especially when
they're
contracting with tech companies i've
heard from teachers even years ago like
there was software
where like an algorithm would serve up
serve kids up news articles
uh and sort of track like how fast it
took them to read them and
you know again sort of curate these
things and it just raises all kinds of
questions about
tech companies monitoring your child's
behavior and sort of
letting their proprietary algorithms
guide their education
in a way that i think like 99.9 of these
companies are full of [ __ ] like they
have some black box algorithm that
doesn't
actually do the thing it says it does
and then they're collecting data on you
the whole time and so i think the
testing
is just an extension of this of you know
maybe college
kids uh are maybe more able to sort of
fight back and their professors are a
little more chill about it
but especially like in a high school
where they have no rights and teachers
are
paid [ __ ] and are just terrified of
losing their jobs like it really worries
me
yeah i i think it this involves like a
misunderstanding of
what humans are and how they work
because i mean even if i was taking an
exam
remotely i might want to like get up and
do a lap around my room to like
brainstorm or think about something i
might lean back in my chair
i might like sip a coffee and i don't
know this reminds me of a time where i
was working someplace where i was
responsible for for having some
writers under me that were contract
workers and the company i worked at
wanted to insist that every writer had
monitoring software on their computer
to watch them and i like through a [ __ ]
fit and which is like no
i was like it's totally fine if
someone's writing some [ __ ] for us
and they take a five-minute break to
look at something online or they
brainstorm or they do something i was
like that's fine that's weird i want
them to be doing that
and this just like makes me think that
we're moving in this direction where in
both
i think we're seeing this in in work
already but now in education we're going
to
treat human beings like they're
algorithmic
robotic things uh that can only focus
one way and it's the thing that's real
[ __ ] up about this
is we know we live in an era where we're
training people to not have attention
we're training people to like be all
over the place and then we're going to
expect them to be these sort of like
focused robots i just hate it
yeah it's it's real black mirror [ __ ] it
really is
and there seems to be no no stopping
this
yeah i i think the problem is that like
tech companies come to schools and
they're like
they come up with some [ __ ]
indicators like are are
do you want to stop 50 and cheating and
they're like oh okay i guess they're
like do you want to make your kids like
five percent more literate and they're
like yeah i don't know i i guess like i
don't know how you're making those
claims but i'll [ __ ]
write a ten thousand dollar check and
it's just a nightmare
and and of course who's paying for this
you know what i mean when these con when
these companies come to these
universities to contract out software
like that
when developers come to take over
student housing whatever it is
this this is a reason why tuition keeps
going up
and the very students who are going into
debt
to pay for this [ __ ] their loan money is
paying for the same software that's
making their lives horrible i'm mad
interestingly there was a study that
said that students
um so they compared students who do
uh who take exams with the software and
without the software
there's only like a two point difference
so it's not like
everybody's like cheating if they're not
being supervised like
it's it's not a big deal um
i can understand if you're taking like
an entrance exam like an mcat or an lsat
or something like that
but when it comes to like as
like a midterm do we need to go to this
extreme
should i like sacrifice my privacy and
data
to assuage my professors concerns that i
didn't look at my textbook
yeah yeah i mean even like
for the mcat or sort of entrance exams i
mean if the goal is to say do you have
this requisite knowledge that you need
to succeed here like i guess
but at the same time i think it's often
like
do you have the most merit but like rich
people can just pay for tens of
thousands of dollars worth of tutors and
so it's not really merit anymore it's
just like
how much money do your parents have or
like do you not have to work
a second or third job you know well and
why why would you cheat on the mcat
anyways because like even if you cheat
on it and you get in you're [ __ ] once
you're there if you don't know anything
i hear med school is not a cakewalk
and i just think that's the difference
right if you're i don't know like i
think a couple times as an undergrad i
cheated a little bit
on on whatever i'll say it um in like a
math class i took because i was really
bad at math so a friend like helped me
with it yeah
but like i'll be honest kids didn't
affect my life went to grad school and
did just fine
because isn't i knew that i wasn't gonna
do math and i knew that i lived in an
era where we had technology
um but of course it's not like i would
cheat in graduate school because like
what would be the point of that if i'm
spending my life doing this and i think
most lawyers and doctors
and and biologists whoever aren't
cheating
because because they actually give a
[ __ ] about this want to make it their
career
and they know how to google things which
is not part of the test taking structure
yes uh anyway
okay and sorry i'm gonna can you think
of one positive
to any of this i wanna see if you can
devil's advocate the whole process
no i think i can't think of a single
positive thing i mean it's not like
you could say something like oh well it
helps students like
learn how to use a new software tool
like there's nothing
i can't think of a single positive ala
can you do it is there one positive you
can think of here
i i'm gonna cheat i'm gonna say like the
good thing about tests is i think
they're really good for learning a
language
because nothing's gonna motivate me to
like read
like 50 index cards with how to say
hello and sneakers
than an actual test wow okay so we will
we'll do it for language stuff
um and i think no positives um but yeah
and we'll get to this later of course
but if you are a current college student
and if you're dealing with this we would
love to hear about it and we'll bug you
about that later
um so one of i'll go ahead sergey
okay there's just one other thing i also
know that they're doing it for on-campus
recruiting
so my cousin was saying that he has to
log into the same sort of software
and there's like an algorithm that will
like track his answers
and depending on how well he performs on
this like pre-interview then he'll get
an interview with a recruiter
bonkers just bonkers god our world is
the last the last thing i'll say and
there's a lot of writing about this that
people want to check it out is there is
an algorithm
to judge teacher performance uh
i think it's called the value-added
teaching model or something like that
uh it's complete [ __ ] uh it it
doesn't work but like people
paid you know tens if not hundreds of
thousands of dollars for this thing that
just didn't work because
there was no there was no transparency
in the algorithm so they could say
whatever the [ __ ] they wanted to say a
lot of good teachers were fired
but i think we should have these
standards or the skepticism when it
comes to like who's getting into school
in the first place
yeah god being evaluated as the teacher
sucks those are the worst afternoons of
my entire life
um okay so um big news
this week i think something that uh we
all heard about we all woke up to news
about we were very excited about
um is news about this pfizer vaccine
trial and they came at us with some
pretty
hot stats that i don't think anyone was
expecting and luckily
we have an expert uh immunologist
virologist vaccine expert
come do him with actual medical advice
um but alec
tell us what we need to know and what
our expectations should be
and all of your expert analysis about
the coven 19 vaccine news
okay i just want to say i'm not immune
uh i can't even say the [ __ ] word to
speak to
you i'm humble you're just humble uh
i've just i i've read uh things and not
like weird google suturing that
anti-vaxxers do but anyway here here's
the basic premise
uh for anyone who doesn't know pfizer
along with biontech which is a german
company
uh developed a kovit 19 vaccine uh they
released a press release that said in
they're in the middle of the trial but
they said so far it looks like it's 90
effective which far exceeds uh anything
people
people were expecting oh maybe it's 60
effective
you know basically you have a 60 chance
of being protected against code if you
get this vaccine which again
sixty percent still good but ninety
percent is is basically amazing
people are very excited uh people are
like oh is the end in sight
um just some sort of uh
i guess the boring stuff out of the way
um it's it's a vaccine that needs two
doses
um it's an mrna vaccine that's messenger
rna which we've never
at least in humans had a vaccine sort of
distributed like that
uh and it's kind of cool because instead
of saying like hey here's the dead virus
or the live virus for your anti
for your immune system to attack and
learn how to attack
uh it sends little messenger rna into
your cells that are like
okay this gives me instructions to make
this protein that protein resembles
the coven 19 protein and then your
antibodies react to that protein
uh so you're turning you're turning your
your own cells into this whole factory
of just this little tiny piece of the
virus
that your immune system can learn to
fight which is really cool
but also it's really shitty in a lot of
ways just in that it's very hard to
store it has to be very cold
a lot of hospitals and places don't have
specialized freezers to to
properly store it and so they're working
on that but it's also probably going to
be a nightmare for distributing this in
places like
you know that are a little less
developed uh even if that's rural places
in america
or rural villages in say like africa or
russia or anything like that um so you
know
there's good and bad but what really
interested me is
um i'm always very interested in
in bad science journalism uh and i'm not
saying any of the the the scientist
here is bad but i think the way that
this is getting interpreted is
uh should lead to some skepticism um
there's
actually a pretty good vox article um
which criticizes the idea of science by
press release um and now
so the the way the vaccine or any drug
process works is there's a trial
that trial publishes the results they
get scrutinized
there have been problems uh with covet
19 vaccine research in that
things were a little bit opaque and
basically there was a lot of pressure
saying hey
pfizer all these other companies are
getting all this public money
you need to show what is the actual
process of these trials so that like
other scientists can scrutinize them and
that that's happening now
um but what pfizer did instead of
finishing the trial and saying here's
the results
we're going to publish them in a
peer-reviewed place and then everyone's
going to scrutinize them they released a
press release
that said hey we're not going to show
you the exact specific results for you
to scrutinize we're just going to say
it's 90 effective trial's not done
now i'm not saying that
this means the vaccine is automatically
bad or anything eventually they will
need to go to that process of publishing
it and getting scrutinized by scientists
and i think at that point like i sort of
trust the process there's
lots of good scientists who are you know
uh
aware of the fact that this is sort of a
rushed process and we need to make sure
this is safe as possible so i don't want
to freak anyone out i don't think
anything like that
as long as the process is allowed to go
through is going to happen at the same
time
they released this press release their
stock mark their their stock price
skyrockets and their ceo sells a bunch
of that stock
now there's basically conspiracy theory
ask being like you know he knows
maybe the the long term like it's maybe
not 90 effective maybe it's only 60 or
70 effective and he's
he's dumping the stock before that comes
out i i don't
there's there's no evidence to support
that except that it's just shady as hell
but this box article talking about this
is a larger problem
of science by press release uh even in
covid19
there have been lots of cases of things
that are very hyped through press
releases
and then the process happens and then
that hype gets deflated
so this is from the article back in may
moderna another company with a
coronavirus vaccine that's far along
clinical trials
put out a press release about promising
phase one results while it first caused
many
the the first caused the company's stock
valuation to swell
vaccine researchers point out in stat
that the information the press release
was far too preliminary and vague to
gauge whether the vaccine was actually
working
also remsav remsetavir in april the
national institute of health announced
via press release on promising results
for hospital patients
later further studies complicated the
picture of the drug's effectiveness and
today it's not clear that remsedever
carries any benefit uh this was touted
by many people
sort of in the present and government as
basically a cure or not even a cure but
you know a wonder drug in the case of
kovid
and the article goes to talk about um
uh regeneron drug regn cov2 which
president trump called a cure in october
most of what we know about effectiveness
comes from a september 29th
press release about a multi-phased
random double-blind clinical trial
involving only 275 people
it's a very small number the pfizer
trials are in the tens of thousands of
peoples
um and so again this isn't people might
hear a lot of anti-vaxxer types saying
like oh the process is [ __ ] don't
trust it and i'm not saying that uh but
i'm saying
uh there might be some hype that gets
deflated by the process so i think
you know not to be a buzzkill don't get
too excited
wow wow
now that we all feel bummed um no so so
here's a question about all of this
um and i agree with you that like i'd
rather have them
say that it's gonna be like 60 and it
ends up being 80
then have them say it's going to be 90
ends up being 70 percent because
happiness is the management of
expectations
um but here's a question
what is going to happen if cause what
there's multiple companies working on
vaccines right and there's
there's a good chance that multiple
companies will have fda approved
vaccines
is this going to create a situation
where like people are
calling their doctor to be like oh i
want the fisher not the modern which one
do you have and creates this weird like
marketplace um around these things in
which people are like
which vaccine did you get i think
just inject them all inside everything
i think there was kind of some discourse
around
that this press release was
intentional in that sense and that there
is a lot of competition and there's
going to be a lot of money for the first
person out the door or the one that
immediately looks more promising
and so i don't actually know about the
specifics uh i was reading a new york
times article about basically how it
gets distributed
where the government has to sort of help
distribute it is it getting sent to
hospitals is it getting sent to nursing
homes
the storage thing is a huge problem uh
will people have to travel to go to
these sort of centralized storage places
and i think it gets so that that's what
i do know and i think it gets even more
complicated of like okay if there's
multiple
are like different states getting
different things are they just going for
the first person and i don't know but
if it was a situation where there was
multiple options i would not be
surprised of basically pharmaceutical
[ __ ] being like
you know seeing ads for trust our
vaccine the most which i think is is
shitty and bad
um especially when they have an
incentive to sort of hype results and
also it's worth knowing that pfizer
has settled massive massive mis uh
fraud claims for mismarketing their
drugs
one i need two seconds to i think
there's noise coming from my speaker
i i've always been cautiously optimistic
about a vaccine like i do think that
there will be a vaccine
um but i'm never really too excited when
i see something in the news about
it because it still has to go through
the peer review process
it still has to be distributed so
i just try to take it like with a grain
of salt like yeah eventually we'll get
there but i'm not involved
so i'll just hang back until i
have more info and everything is settled
i think like the scariest thing with all
this too is
and i get why our dumb human brains do
this
but you know i've known people that for
months we've heard you know there might
be a vaccine by late 2020 early 21
um and i think people's minds go cool
well whatever day it's approved i'll
automatically have it inside my body and
it'll be there and i think a lot of
people's brain doesn't then jump to
just because it's approved you know it
could be six months until i have access
to this thing and there was a i forget
who wrote it there was an editorial in
new york times this week by
two two doctors or scientists it was
kind of saying like hey
the reaction to this shouldn't be
everything's fine let's be reckless now
if anything it should be let's tighten
up as much as possible
um so that when this does become
available we're in a good place
and uh you know dr michael osterholm
from the university of minnesota
uh who i guess is is a part of the you
know the next presidential task force on
covid
you know he put out a statement
yesterday that said something effective
like
the best thing to do even with a vaccine
is a four to six week lockdown
get numbers as low as possible keep that
tight so
then when we get a vaccine it's able to
be much more effective much quicker
and i think there is that fear that
hearing news like this
makes people preemptively reckless or
act as if
like the magical cure is on the way yeah
and i think everyone
public health officials are worried
about that and i do want to clear up one
thing in the comments everyone's like
this isn't a pfizer vaccine this is a
german vaccine
and also i think the the creators
specifically are like uh immigrants
maybe from turkey or turkish uh
so yes uh it is developed by a german
company who didn't have the
know-how or the resources to do a
large-scale clinical trial so they
partnered with pfizer who did all that
stuff
um so i i don't mean to try to take all
the glory to the american
pfizer because uh pfizer sucks but uh to
your
point yeah i mean the the greatest thing
with a
a vaccine like if we
the way that outbreaks of normal
diseases often works let's say like
smallpox or or even you know
polio in countries that don't have a lot
of polio is oh there's an outbreak and
you know there's a confirmed case this
person who later developed smallpox
walked into bar we're gonna find every
person who's in that bar and give them
this vaccine
and then you're talking about
inoculating a handful of people instead
of
hundreds of millions of people and so
right now
you know anthony fauci said something to
the effect of you know we expect to
hopefully get this vaccine
to everyone uh by april but you know
again through this like
huge huge huge public infrastructure
huge investment and i'm not saying that
that's bad but like
if we were in a better place uh where
there was less cases we could do
basically a containment strategy and
then we wouldn't have to be
sitting inside all day not seeing our
family for thanksgiving
yes uh yes sorry go ahead sergey
i'm really nervous to take the vaccine
so i don't have
my body doesn't react well to vaccines
um like when i took the hep a vaccine i
had
hives for two years two years covering
covering my entire body um constantly
so it wasn't just like oh i had it for
like a couple hours like it was 24 7 for
two years i had hives
and when i take the flu vaccine i
have a lot of problems with that as well
and so i'm
so nervous to take the coping vaccine
you should you should talk to your
you should talk to your doctor and
because for instance the flu vaccine
the flu vaccine is incubated i think in
chicken eggs and some people are
allergic to it and so there's like
hypoallergenic versions of the vaccine
if anyone has reactions to stuff that
could be why and so
people do can have whether sometimes
they get fever sometimes they get rash
stuff like that
these are all sort of expected things
from vaccines but like talk to your
doctor
cite your concerns and also uh there was
a published article that said people
uh for this is about mrna vaccines in
general
basically theorize that people with
autoimmune issues
may have issues with mrna vaccines
specifically
i'm not a doctor i'd invent this article
talk to your [ __ ] doctor
even if you're worried about allergic
reaction serbia or whoever's listening
talk to your doctor they're going to
know better than strangers on the
internet
talk to your doctor i mean even if you
even if you're fine with this
and you're just feeling lonely talk talk
to your doctor even if you
want to talk about sports talk to your
doctor relationship advice
so yeah survey totally justified to feel
feel nervous if you've had
you know previous problems in the past
uh
talk to your doctor talk to your doctor
but then maybe maybe serbia this is one
of those hopeful things where
having a bunch of different companies
working about it it will have different
options and you will be able to talk to
your physician and they'll be able to
say hey
pfizer maybe not for you but the walmart
one
really good for you and the amazon
version
is is going to be the best one for you
because mark my words next pandemic
bezos will be making the vaccine or
paying for it i also want to say to alex
just with talking about pfizer
i do feel like we i'm trying to like
mentally
wall off my hatred and that this the
scientists who are
like the researchers are awesome it's
just like the damn company that takes
their research and turns it into a
profit-making thing
are the ones i feel like yeah totally
and that's the thing i wish
anti-vaxxers understood is like there's
this like evil
infrastructure but like the the science
when science you know the evil
infrastructure causes some not great
things but like science is still
you know we've got peer review we have
independent scientists who can publish
articles being like hey
you're doing a fraud here stop doing
that and uh yeah yeah
as i learned in the movie contagion most
researchers are good
um it's everyone else is bad okay so
unless there's any other thoughts on
this
um cool i will segue then
so this this relates well we'll kind of
stay on covet but mellow out a little
bit
an issue and a thing that is coming up
is the holidays
um and normally during the holidays we
we get excited we
get on overcrowded airplanes that are
delayed
and we go stay in a room that we don't
like anymore in a bed that's too small
to hang around family members that are
low-key racist but we laugh and put up
with it or whatever it might be
this year the holidays are complicated
and
there's an article in particular that
was published in advice a couple weeks
ago
called how to tell your family you're
not coming home for the holidays that
deals with the issue
of familial expectations versus
individual
feelings of safety health and just
basically like making good decisions
around thanksgiving and then christmas
um
now i don't know about about you all um
i'm
i feel lucky because i have not been
pressured to go home
or go anywhere for the holidays so i
haven't had to like come up with lies
but i do know a lot of people who maybe
their parents
don't take things as seriously um and
i've definitely encountered a lot of
people who magically think that you
can't get sick from someone you're
related to
because i've heard multiple times people
say like oh no but we're family
their journeys are my germs like we have
yes it's a real thing and i've like
i've given [ __ ] to people who are like
no no but it's okay because it's like it
was my mom and sister
i'm like oh okay that's great just
coughing their mouths then
um but so i think a lot of people are
dealing with this right now so i thought
this article was interesting and sort of
talking through
ways you can do this so they give you
some advice
for if you are are struggling to talk to
your family
they give you lines you can say like you
know traveling and celebrating
the holidays during a pandemic is
incredibly risky for a number of reasons
and i'm just not comfortable doing it
if you don't want to be that honest it
doesn't make sense for me to spend this
much time money energy
to make this trip this one i really like
i get so few days off and i'd like to
use them to relax and recharge not to
travel to my
boring hometown and then this isn't all
of them all of these sound awful by the
way i'm i'm saying like it's good to
give excuses but
none of these would work yeah but i like
this one too
um it says insert sibling hasn't spent
the holidays with family every single
year and it's been okay
so like throw a sibling under the bus
yeah um
now of course like i think that these
some of these excuses
seem silly but i think they're here for
like a reason because
i think no matter how maybe smart or
realistic your family is about this
people get their feelings hurt and i
think i think a lot of us might feel
pressured to do things we don't want to
do because we don't want to let our
family down or whatever it is
so i thought the most interesting uh
thing in this advice
in this article is to like be wait how
do they phrase this
um it says be firm and honest
while still being kind so it tells you
you can
be honest uh while still being kind and
then it gives you some clues uh some
tips on what to say about the
coronavirus as well
but i mean i wanted to ask you all
because i know i i think we're entering
into this era that a lot of people have
been freaked out by
where things were getting better in the
fall but then it was like uh oh
halloween a lot of people are gonna get
together no matter what and that'll be a
little spread
then thanksgiving people especially in
the colder states are going to cram
together inside and have little super
spreader parties with cranberry sauce
and that'll be a whole thing and then
you know the winter holidays christmas
then into new year's it's like two
months of
you know a super spreader event every
three weeks and i think this is
especially pertinent now that
with the news that came out that chicago
is going to shut down completely
uh for a month which means thanksgiving
is is technically canceled
um so what do you all think about sort
of the
the home for the holidays pressure has
this affected
you at all do you think there's any
smart way to do this
let's start with that i'm curious what
are what are y'all situations with
with home for the holiday family
pressure serbia is the most socially
adjusted person what do you think um
so i
i so thanksgiving is not like a big deal
in my family and i have some
local family that i'll like my
grandparents like they don't go out of
the house i don't go out of the house so
i'll probably see them for thanksgiving
um christmas is a huge celebration in my
family i think like 50 to 60 people
usually get together
so that hasn't been discussed this year
um
but i could see around december
a what's that message going out that's
like hey why don't we all self-isolate
and get together um but
i i'm i'm very honest and very
transparent
maybe it makes people uncomfortable too
so i would have no problem saying that's
[ __ ] stupid and i don't feel
comfortable doing that
my mom is a lot more gracious so she
would likely say something like oh
unfortunately that won't work out for us
this year like
thank you for inviting us yeah um
i i think though that like it really
depends on your family and
you can't be honest like some families
are horrible like you can't
say i don't feel comfortable traveling
with a pandemic you have to lie
the thing that i run into is
like a a grandparent asked me if i was
coming this was like a month ago like
so you guys aren't coming down for
thanksgiving are you
uh but it was kind of like an invitation
and i was and i said no but i want to be
like no and how dare you
you live in florida which is a nightmare
currently um
so there's that um
but i'm a bad person uh i think the
the other tricky thing is going to be
and this is gonna get trickier the
larger the gathering is
like people in my family were like oh
let's all quarantine for two weeks and
then spend christmas together
uh and at first i was like yeah that
might be okay then i started to think
about it
and i just think people
people aren't aware of the things that
they are do that they're doing
that are risky behavior like people's
ideas of quarantine might be different
and like when it's just about like a
couple members of my direct family like
i have a pretty good sense of like
i'm pretty sure this person thinks
quarantining means like eating outside
at restaurants and
like getting his hair cut like 13 times
so like even if he says he's
quarantining like i don't trust it and
then there's other
stuff like that but then we were talking
about like let's say 20 people
it like what level that's a person i
know then there's
the people that you don't know like you
know
is your grandma having a poker night
with her like 18 friends but that for
some that they're not they're in a
bubble but not everyone knows that
they're in a bubble together
and so that freaks me out and even me
personally uh
i was like hey i can quarantine for two
weeks but because i live in an apartment
building i really can't like truly
quarantine
and not leave the house because like i
have to go in common areas to throw out
trash and see people sometimes they're
not wearing masks and
just stuff like that and so i i think
that's also
what worries me is like uh we're
quarantined but no one's actually
quarantining
yeah and anything with that i've heard
some some friends and family talk about
doing similar things
but then i'm like well if you're also
not testing then that just means nothing
to me
like if i had family that wanted to do a
quarantine thing i'm like okay
well then i would want everyone to like
test at the beginning test at the end
and be really sure but it just seems
like in all the examples we've seen
of people trying to do normal stuff
uh and i hate to bring this up again the
only group that's made it work is the
nba the only group
um all of these other professional
sports leagues that are happening right
now whether it be
you know soccer football baseball i mean
it's not like they're being like
idiots these are multi-billion dollar
organizations
where they're testing rapidly every day
everyone's pretty much doing their own
thing they have doctors on call
and still there's outbreaks in nfl teams
was outbreaks in mlb teams
that it's still happening the only way
we've seen anyone get a hold of this is
a super comprehensive
really gnarly quarantine bubble
situation and and what i worry
is that i think what we do with family
or what i worry about is everyone
self-exceptionalizes
yeah so their family's the safe one
they're they're they're the good ones
that no one has to worry about
and i think you know and it's a little
silly to say but
when everyone exceptionalizes then there
is no exception
and everyone's putting themselves at
risk and i think the biggest
thing that i worry about with with
thanksgiving is it getting compounded by
christmas
so whatever spreads then goes there
but i still have sympathy for people
especially younger people like college
age people or people right out of
college
um who might have pressure who might not
have had the thing yet where they've
said
no to their family so one thing that
comes up in that vice article
is rather than being like [ __ ] you
you're stupid i'm not doing it
is to suggest an alternative so i think
that is one thing people should think
about if you're gonna say no
if you want to get out of it maybe think
of something else maybe come up with a
fun
uh online thing to do maybe do some sort
of like distanced
outside thing if you can i mean in
general you shouldn't be doing stuff
inside
but can you all think of any
alternatives that people could do
yeah you can [ __ ] lie and say you're
not feeling well
and you're concerned that you have
covered there you go guys
or just say like yeah yeah i would love
to come to christmas i'm gonna do it
and then don't ever book your ticket
don't ever make plans to drive
and then like a week before be like i
have a bad cough well just call your mom
and be like mom
okay christmas and then see what she
does
yeah and she says come home anyways your
mom's a psychopath uh
we do have a quick correction from john
who says uh the nhl also did a
successful bubble show respect to the
hockey the best sport
that's john i didn't say that john i'll
say this
i like hockey a lot i think it's a good
sport i don't think it's the best sport
but i think it's a really good sport
um and yeah sorry i did not i didn't did
not acknowledge the
an nhl bubble they did a good job as
well and i think their model was similar
to the
the uh the mba model so sorry about that
sorry to the entire uh country of canada
as well
um thanks john and also sorry to mail
who's been donating
thank you so much oh thank you awesome
thank you so much
um so yes so i think uh main just here
is we're all gonna be good
you should all be good and you know what
if how about this if anyone
needs help um you can email us
give us your specific scenario and we
will construct
an out for you um it might be
uncomfortable we might
ask you to say something that is going
to sever relationships
but we will give that to you i will
always email to your mom
a trio of noted podcast hosts have
said i can't come home and here's why
yeah i'm fine with that
also too i'll just say this is what i've
been trying to do hype up
next year if you need to tell your
friends and family say hey
it really sucks i wish we could all be
together but you know what i just want
to be safe so next year can be awesome i
want to be good now
so we can be reckless then and i think
that's a helpful thing as well because
you give them something to look forward
to
uh any other thoughts on this one before
we move on
saying no to your family is hard so
if you have to do that i empathize yeah
but you can do it i believe in you it's
like a band-aid it's it's so hard to say
no to your family for the first time
but then you rip it off and then they're
like oh
wow someone's a grown-up now and you'll
get a little [ __ ]
but then you'll you'll earn their
respects so watch some mob movies and
learn about how respect operates and
then just do that
i learned how to deal with my family by
watching good bell got good fellas
uh okay so well this relates then to the
next thing i wanted to tell everyone
um along with wanting to give you
tips for how to get out of hanging out
with your family on the holidays um
we want to give you advice about
anything or hear advice from you about
anything
or have you comment on things we're
talking about or have you tell us things
you want to hear us talk about and how
can you do that you can email us you can
call us
okay you can email us at culturebinge
wisecrack.com
no m drop vm okay
culturevideowisecrack.com or
call us we love to hear your voices
eight zero 213-534-8807 that is two one
three five three four eight eight zero
seven
write us and call us with any type of
inquiry thought
comment or help and mediating awkward
family situations
uh especially leave us a voicemail it's
gonna
our next episode is gonna be after
thanksgiving but if you need a christmas
excuse
let's do that call us tell us your
circumstances we will create you
an excuse yeah or what you could do is
call us and then and then and then do
like three-way calling
then call into your family so you leave
us a message
that's you telling your family member
that you're not coming home
and you will hear their reaction so if
if someone can figure out how to do that
you would be a hero and a legend in your
field
and we would put you on the culture
binge uh
uh family mount rushmore um bccs on any
emails you send to your family telling
them yeah
get us involved or you know what we
could do a skype thing where we set up a
call
and we bro listen we'll make it weird
help us do it but that said um it's been
a few weeks
uh we've heard from a lot of you al alec
what if what what if our family
told us in the meantime what sort of uh
calls and emails do we got this time
around
just emails this week but we got three
good ones well two
three good ones one of them is angry so
i'm excited for that i know
uh this first one's from daniel uh it
says hey wisecrack crew
up late listening to episode 40 and was
struck with a realization of why serbia
segment on influencers asking for free
[ __ ] feels so bad
because it's a power imbalance these
influencers hold more power than the
small business owner and feel predatory
in their business trade
because the small business doesn't have
the knowledge to know what they will get
in return for their deal and their
participation
will have relatively greater impact on
them than the impact on a multi-million
dollar company
the way we should which an influencer
asks is probably different than
the way a bill murray type would ask
entitlement versus humility
and we feel empathy and humanize the
small business compared to the faceless
evil catholics corporation
and also to michael's point we often
feel these influencers don't have skill
to represent the business item they are
to advertise
as compared to an expert reviewing the
quality of product
yeah thanks dan thank you
i agree with that i think it's a good
point
and i feel like unless you have a
background in like marketing or
advertising
i'd really want to see what the roi
would be if i hire you as an influencer
for my brand
yeah i do want to interject with just
one amazing comment i saw this is rubish
just tell your family they're horrible
if they invite anyone and hang the phone
love it if you have that bravery and
courage
do it um and as to the the email from
dan as well i was thinking about this
because
you know i think is better than
influencers just like really good
targeted advertising i was with some
friends recently who were just saying
they bought a bunch of different
products because they get targeted
instagram ads and it's like hyper
specific
if they're like wine nerds it's like oh
here's this cool new wine fridge thing
or
here's this cool new outdoor fireplace
and at least that way like
i don't know i'd rather see a targeted
ad and read about it for myself
than see some like you know loser
jabroni tell me to
get something because they got paid to
have it i gotta target an ad for a dog
sleeping bag
i don't i don't own a dog but i want to
buy a dog just so i could get the
sleeping bag also i love dogs so this
isn't a weird
animal neglect thing wow it is weird to
hear the algorithm fail
you know what this means though the
algorithm never fails so you should be
you should by every match knows i like
camping
and also knows i like dogs and so really
it's even more effective because now i'm
thinking about getting a dog
anyway wow what else do we got besides
the algorithm predicting what you're
going to do in the future there's an
email from
uh maria which uh circulated all around
the wisecrack office uh so
last week we talked or two weeks ago
maybe three weeks ago we talked about
jeffrey toobin
the new yorker writer who was whacking
it on a business call
uh he has since been fired yep
uh some other stuff came out apparently
he's like uh got a
pattern of creepiness in different ways
not necessarily masturbatory
but here's maria yeah here's maria's
email
hey culture binge i'm a longtime
listener who's argentinian but grew up
in the states and then back in buenos
aires
now on your last episode you mentioned a
man who jerked off on zoom and i
couldn't help but share what happened
here recently with
a senator during a virtual session of
congress on zoom he apparently also
thought he had his microphone and video
off and proceeded to greet a woman next
to him by pulling down her shirt and
kissing her exposed breast
the worst part was his apology
explaining that she had gotten breast
enhancement surgery a few days ago
oh he had to resign of course the the
resignation i think
surprises me but anyway uh attaching an
article so you can read more
yeah thank you guys for your content i'm
such a big fan enjoy it so much all from
architecture wait who is the person
in relation to him i think it was
a girlfriend or a mistress okay
uh i don't maybe it was his wife but i
feel like if it's your wife that's
unfortunate
but it's not like predatory yeah
in my mind it was like oh this is like a
consensual thing that doesn't seem like
a man being an exhibitionist
um but you know some countries just have
higher standards for their people in
public office can do and
i'm not going to argue i feel like if
you wouldn't have told me the country i
would have completely thought that was
from italy that just seems like a very
yeah it seems like something berlusconi
would do yeah exactly yeah
should start dating italian guys
uh well serbia what do you think
um i i mean i don't think it's that big
of a deal
it's not like i mean it was like a
consensual thing it was just like hey
how are you doing um like if i saw that
i'd be like oh [ __ ]
but i wouldn't be like [ __ ] that guy i
feel violated
yeah um but and there have been times
where i've been on zoom calls with like
very poor
approp inappropriate things where i have
felt like that
needs that should be reported to hr um
but this is not something i mean i would
probably immediately
slack him and be like you need to
[ __ ] turn your camera off yeah
yeah i and i wonder too i would i want
to know
more about this person if they were like
a bad shitty politician that's great but
what if they were like
just man of the people a real a real
hero for the working classes of
argentina
and then they got fired just because
they appreciated their their wife
but probably not they're probably a
slime ball we'll look into it but thank
you that's like the best
email ever uh
yeah thank you so much maria uh sent us
more emails about crazy shopping
yes maria can you be our our buenos
aires culture correspondent
anything cool or zany happening in
argentina just let us know
uh on the ground reporting yeah uh the
last email is from ryan uh
ryan sent us a pretty salty email but
ryan said that he is generally a fan so
i was like you know what
ryan said something nice and then said a
bunch of mean things and so
i will read part of ryan's email the
other part is yelling at me for hiking
i don't want to get into that it'll be a
whole thing but here's ryan's email
i was listening your colt philosophy
podcast today i want to say i'm
generally a big fan of everything
wisecrack especially
youtube michael and alec where's the
serbia love ryan but that's okay but i
say i'm extraordinarily disappointed in
your blindness to reality when it comes
to
the uh topic regarding the dating scene
uh ryan believes it's hilariously naive
the aids epidemic in the 80s
also had an effect even arguably a
long-term effect on dating but it didn't
lead people to abandon
romantic interactions with strangers i
understand that being in long-term
relationships for so long
must have estranged youtube from the
reality of the dating world but
spontaneity isn't going away anytime
soon that's the one thing i want to talk
about in this email because i i thought
i genuinely like emails we're often
talking on the fly about i'm not a
dating expert
as ryan pointed out i've been in a
relationship and and and disconnected
from this world
so we love well-intentioned
criticisms what we're doing but serbia
as the token single person
what do you think
you know that i'm still heartbroken i
mean this was really devastating to me
um i i don't know that we said that
spontaneity would go away i
i think that it's just opening up
another avenue
um yeah but i don't i don't know if i
said that
like i think that i think that dating
will change
um but i don't i don't really remember
exactly what the conversation was
but also but also the thing that i think
i disagree with is that
aids like had a huge long-lasting impact
which i know ryan says but
you know it basically killed free love
um you know
large to this day like lots of gay men i
know are basically terrified of hiv and
so
there's drugs that uh count uh i forget
what they're called prepping
uh but basically they are defenses
preemptively against hiv and like
lots of gay men take them because
they're horrified and that
allows them gives them you know leeway
to not you know
to hook up with people and not
necessarily always be terrified but
they're often terrified nonetheless and
so
you know when it comes to like uh stigma
against
unprotected obviously people still have
unprotected sex obviously
you know uh people still go on dating
sites and [ __ ] strangers or go on grindr
and [ __ ] strangers obviously that still
happens but like
it's clearly had a long lasting impact
and i'm not saying
after the pandemic you know hiv is still
around
covid hopefully after a vaccine will not
be
prevalent in the way that hiv is and so
it's not going to create it's not going
to have that long lasting impact but i
think people will
possibly explore new ways of like
interacting with the dating sphere is
all we were saying
yeah and i'll say to total fairness to
ryan like
i'm i'm washed man the last time i was
single
we didn't i i was let me think
i was single right when tinder came out
and it was a thing that was only in a
few east coast cities and like new york
friends told me about it when i got on
it in baltimore there was like
three people on it and like we all just
dated each other in a circle for two
weeks and it got weird
um we that's not true serbia that
wouldn't happen
but um but no so i i totally confess to
to being washed i've been in a
relationship for a while and because i'm
obnoxiously faithful i don't go date on
the side
um i do think what was said though was i
think there was worry expressed about in
general
you know people losing that ability to
kind of like organically and
spontaneously have interactions right
now
which isn't the fault of the people it's
just like undercover i'm not gonna like
walk up to someone in the grocery store
pull my mask down and be like
yo girl what's up let me see what's in
your basket um
but i think like if anything maybe this
is agreeing with ryan
i kind of think if we get vaccinated
once people
shake off like 18 months of looking at
every other human as a potential vector
of disease which i think is gonna have a
long-term psychological effect we're
gonna have to deal with
i think we might get back to the era of
things being a little more
organic like i don't know like i met my
current partner by like happening to sit
next to each other in a coffee shop and
we just started talking because that
didn't feel weird or intrusive
um and yeah it's beautiful it's
beautiful join
join our patreon and i'll tell you the
whole story but um
but um no one wants to hear that but no
i think that maybe to ryan's point there
could be
a new golden era of organic social
interaction because we're all going to
miss that and maybe once we get back and
are at coffee shops
and and bars and like underground sex
clubs again
we're going to want to have those fun
conversations and get to know people so
i i hope you're right and i'm sorry if
if at least two of us who are just
washed and our opinions are trash
i apologize for that i also want to hear
more about why alex shouldn't hike but i
guess i'll ask him off air
uh brian was basically like correctly
like you're the most precautious person
on air uh yeah like i'm a regularly
germaphobe anyway and so you know like i
don't leave my house as much
but called me a hypocrite for hiking
exposing these rural populations to
covet
and listen if i was doing that in april
when usc was a hot spot and covet hadn't
spread all around the country but
new york city first of all there's no
travel restriction you know there's like
a free float people are commuting
from upstate new york into the city
they're going back you know farmers are
coming to sell their [ __ ]
there's free flow between connecticut
new york new jersey
and i'm getting in a car i'm going to a
trail
i'm wearing my mask which the local
people don't do and it's not like
i'm bringing my big city germs there
like new york city has had well
recently it's going back up again and i
will reevaluate this behavior but like
had one of the lowest covered rates in
the world like possibly not the world
sorry
the world's great the country and so
i don't know i feel like it's not
bringing my big city germs
going on trail wearing a mask stepping
aside
more than six feet when people are are
there it's not like i'm going to burger
king and coughing
on everyone uh and so i don't know i'm
sorry i didn't want to get into this
whole thing because it's such a lame
argument but ryan no
i brought it up i did but you know but
either way i appreciate this and i think
everyone should know
you can disagree with us we can disagree
with you to get back to the thanksgiving
and christmas thing
we're family and family can love each
other without always seeing the same way
so i hope you know when you email us
when you call us
you're not trying to suck up to us we're
not trying to suck up to you let's be
real with each other okay but let's do
it in a spirit of knowing that no one's
perfect
and we're all trying our best to to you
know
live up to the spiritual perfection that
we see around us so you know
alex going to try better ryan i'm going
to i'm going to stay on him he's going
to try better i i want people to let me
know if they think i'm trash for height
because i
i feel like ryan respectfully ryan i
believe you're wrong about the hiking
thing but
if 20 people email me and tell me i'm
trash we're going upstate and hiking
i i want that feedback yeah so
culturemidgetwisecrack.com213534887
answer questions like is alec trasher
going hiking um
are we watched for thinking that covet
is going to make dating weird
do you know a really cool italian guy
that's looking to meet
a really great person that i don't know
serbia could talk about because earlier
she made a comment about wanting me to
italian guys i don't know
use our email to get this i think
serbia's now going to say please don't
do that
well i was going to say if you've been
to a sex club please let me know because
i've always been very curious
um a friend of mine and i have talked
about it there's underground sex
clubs in la right now that are staying
open illegally that celebrities go to i
saw it on this instagram account i
follow i can't get too into it
but it's happening it's real i have all
the info
i know the password i'll give you the
password you show up
you knock three times is this real
say peanut butter m m's um the the last
three things i said are false but there
really are underground sex clubs that
are
uh i guess a lot of celebrities go to in
l.a that have illegally stayed open i'm
sure a lot of places have this so
if you know about sex clubs call and
write us we'd love to hear about that
from an anthropological perspective just
don't say anything too weird
um that said besides emailing and
calling
if people just wanna to see what you
have to say if they wanna know what you
think about the hot topics of the day
where can they find you online
serbia oh siripatel22 on twitter
alec i'm on twitter at wisecrack alec
make all dumb jokes your twitter is
great though what's your twitter
my twitter is not great uh michael o
burns
and then uh instagram's the same thing i
just have underscores on both sides of
the o
um so come find us there come talk to us
and most importantly come back in wait a
second are we going to be here in two
weeks
because that's thanksgiving week uh
we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out we'll be back soon
we'll be back in two-ish weeks
write call we love you thanks for being
here we missed you and we'll be back
then later guys
bye
you